I wanted to touch on how you were saying
like in the animal kingdom you know
depression doesn't exist it's about a
year ago I started getting divorced and
therapists and everybody's like oh he's
got depression it was dealing with that
at first and then like once I learned
the mindset part and changed my mindset
I was just like it's not a diagnosis
it's just a way of being stuck in a
certain mindset it's just a shitty time
in your life man in society today we're
we're way too quick to like embrace the
victim mindset and the victim mindset's
a loser's mindset people that get stuck
in a cycle of constantly losing in life
I stay away from them I keep them at
arm's length I don't even care if it's a
family member man I just won't deal with
them on a long-term basis arm's length
right you know like if you just want to
keep losing in life and that's fine I'm
about winning and I want to surround
myself with winners you know like shit's
gonna happen you divorce happens bad
financial you know choices happen you
know you lose money you get your heart
broken you know whatever you're a man is
basically what I'm saying it's like you
know you have the burden of performance
just get it done